Giacomo Vuoi provare il mio nuovo camion
super power tubo super tu lo sai che io
a casa ho un carro armato vero che è
grande Coco Guarda qui Ah lì Mia mamma
dice che non posso fare il bagno però
possiamo giocare senza entrare in acqua
che arriva prima lì è il guerriero più
forte di tutto il mondo dell'universo
vai
vampiri non si può correre a bordo
piscina Mi scusi non lo fa non lo
facciamo più con frazzo poi quello
infradito tieni anche in piscina bro già
lo sai niente ieri ho visto quella
maranzina bro ci sta troppo Solo che
adesso mi iscrivo sempre io non mi
faccio incatenare Brody walla già lo sai
ragazzi Spegnete quelle cazzo non siete
mica a casa vostra o scemo di merda vola
in basso perché in alto volano di
schiaffi il brow pensa di dirmi quello
che devo fare Vieni qui si ha il
coraggio Vieni oh scusate no tranquilli
Eh tutto a posto non ci sono problemi
Ecco bravo già lo sai che fine avevi
fatto lo vedi questa sac à poche tu
neanche tra 20 anni te la potrai
permettere Voilà già lo sai